this is steve uh i'm starting this
series called steve summers sessions
where i'm going to answer questions that
you will send to me i hope uh via
twitter
uh hashtags ask steve
and uh once a week i'm going to answer
them here in the month of june and
perhaps beyond if the if there's enough
interest
and i'm going to try to answer two
questions every week
this week i'm going to answer two of the
questions that were submitted to me
through twitter the first one is
how do you improve reading comprehension
i find this a real problem
all right now
my most recent language is romanian so
i'll describe basically how i've gone
through it in the case of romanian but
it applies to all languages first of all
the bottom line as people like to say
in improving your reading comprehension
is to read as much as possible
so much in language learning comes down
to
massive exposure
massive involvement massive time
commitment massive immersion things of
that nature but
obviously to read the more interesting
the content the better your retention is
going to be if you are interested
in the subject matter then you'll have a
better chance of understanding
the subject matter if you are familiar
with the subject matter this has been
proven many times
more necessarily than than studying a
vocabulary list the number one issue is
are you familiar with the subject are
you interested in the subject okay now
when we are learning a language the
problem often is that to begin with
uh most of the content you're that you
would be interested in is too difficult
for you and the content that is
available for you the beginner material
is not interesting so there's no there's
no sense of
of involvement or attachment so the in
an initial period you have to go through
reading things that are not interesting
now as much as possible
listen to what you read and read what
you listen to
um
you know i once bought a russian book on
history and the people who produced it
somewhere in the states made a big deal
of the fact that their audio didn't
correspond to the texts well why would
you possibly do that
um when you are listening and when you
are reading you're trying to pay
attention to words and phrases you're
trying to get them sort of uh ingrained
in your in in your mind and so therefore
the the repetition that you would get by
reading something and then listening to
it and noticing
uh certain structures or certain words
even though other
parts of what you're listening to will
remain unclear for quite a while but as
you're able to nail down a few then
you're able to focus your attention on
the others so
read what you listen to listen to what
you read
the next thing is when you're starting
out in the language you in my experience
you have to listen often and read often
to the same material
and as you progress that is less and
less the case and obviously when you
begin uh you're dealing with short
passages in terms of the length of time
maybe 20 30 40 seconds long
uh even though you might stack three or
four of them
uh together and then review the first
one again you're still dealing with
short passages and as you progress the
passages become
longer
uh
i
like obviously working initially on the
computer where i have access to online
dictionaries
saves me the time of looking things up
or
you know in the case of sometimes there
are people who like bilingual texts
asimil has translations personally i
don't like them personally i prefer to
pick out the words and phrases
uh within the text that i'm reading
try to get a handle on what they mean
and over time i accumulate more and more
of these words and phrases and so i'm
able to make sense of more and more of
the text so my advice on reading
comprehension is a fairly long period of
time where you're working with a
computer now again in my case i uh
initially work on the computer just to
look up words because it's faster but
when i read it the second or third time
or sometimes i just go through very
quickly looking at words and then i read
it
at my ledger on my ipad or iphone so we
have these tools that enables us enable
us to do our reading away from the
computer however
one last thing on reading comprehension
you have to get to where you can read
books you eventually have to develop
that sense of independence from the
computer and even if you i when i read
on paper when i read books i never look
up words because this is a different
thing and i think it's very important in
one's sort of progression towards being
able to read well that you actually take
on a book and i've often likened this to
climbing mount everest the first
full-length book you read in the
language away from the computer is a
major achievement and ultimately if you
want to have good reading comprehension
you need to read books and i'll just
finish off by saying that reading
comprehension is very important for
accumulating vocabulary for getting a
sense of the language finding things
that you notice about the language so
reading a lot
both with the computer initially and
then increasingly away from the computer
is very important for your reading
comprehension and your language skills
generally now the second question i got
was
how do i get from input to output
many of you know that i stress input
listening and reading as being a very
cost effective and time effective and
portable efficient way of
improving your language skills but all
of us our
eventual goal is to speak the language
and in many cases to speak it well so
how do you get from input to output all
right first thing to remember is it to
some extent it depends on your goals if
all you want to output is hello my name
is so and so
could you please tell me where the bus
station is then you can do that fairly
soon
but if our goal is to develop the
ability to have meaningful conversations
with people who share
interests with us so that we can join
with people socially and go out and
participate in conversations and speak
then that's a different order so
when it comes to output the only way to
get good at output eventually is to
speak and write and when you start
speaking you're going to have difficulty
you are going to stumble you won't
remember all the words that you thought
you could remember
so
my advice here is focus initially on a
lot of input
build up your vocabulary build up your
familiarity because
your input skills in my opinion are very
important for your output skills if you
want to have a meaningful conversation
you have to understand what the other
person is saying it's not enough to trot
out a few sentences and then face a
deluge of
the target language back at you and not
understand what the person said
so
i prefer to build up my
call them passive skills through a lot
of listening and reading and building up
my vocabulary
so that when i start speaking
a i have a chance because i understand
what the person is saying
i hope
and and b i can already get involved in
some meaningful conversations
it's just as as was the case with
reading comprehension you have to push
yourself to a level where
what you're talking about just as was
the case with reading comprehension what
you're reading is actually meaningful to
you
you don't want or personally i don't
want to be limited to artificial
situations such as the role playing that
takes place in classrooms i want to get
to where i'm having meaningful
conversations so i put a lot of emphasis
on building up that passive vocabulary
that comprehension capability through
very heavy you know investment of time
in input now when i start to speak i
know i'm going to stumble
so i don't stop my input activities the
speaking the output is often a way to
discover where my gaps are i didn't
notice certain things i'm not using the
subjunctive uh correctly because
uh
and when i went to speak i realized that
i made a mistake or i was looking for a
word then i'm more attentive to that
when i'm listening and reading but uh
you just have to find to get really good
at output you have to find more and more
opportunity to speak some people are
willing to uh you know have the
discipline to write if you have that
discipline writing is excellent and if
you are writing if you are preparing for
an exam or for uh
you know where you're going to be tested
then absolutely you should write because
when you're writing you have time to
think about what you're going to say you
can look things up you can look up the
correct tense you can look up the
correct ending
and you you're more likely to use
some of your recently learned words in
writing than you are in speaking and so
once you have some practice doing that
in writing then
you're more likely to start using some
of these words when you speak but
ultimately you just have to speak a lot
another thing about outfit is don't
worry about how you sound don't worry
about your pronunciation don't worry
about the mistakes you make focus on
communication
and that's another reason why
in seeking out people to talk to
uh don't
i'm not a fan of the idea that you
arrive in some town and
go up to people and say here i am i'm
learning your language and would you
mind talking to me to me that's not a
meaningful situation i prefer to build
up my skills to the point where i can
actually have a genuine interaction with
a person and that the person will not
feel that they're just humoring me but
that they'll actually be
willing to you know converse with me and
i have found that this has worked
uh
you know so uh my advice on output is
continue your input activities
when you already start the output
activities right if you have the
discipline talk to people in meaningful
situations
uh make sure you've prepared yourself so
that you understand what they're saying
don't worry about your mistakes
and when you finish an interaction with
someone regroup
think about
where you had problems and then start
again trying to notice those uh
structures or those vocabulary items in
your input activities but if you can
find an opportunity to totally immerse
yourself in the language where you're
operating in the language either because
you've visited there or you've lined up
three hours a day of skype conversations
you're going to have to do that kind of
thing to really move your output
capabilities up to that level so there
you have it um two answers and uh next
week i am going to answer two other
questions one is do i recommend
studying two languages at once or one at
a time
and what is my take on spaced repetition
systems srs and sentence mining so those
are going to be the questions that i
will answer next week thank you for
listening
you